in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
Though reading from the Sinaxadion for October 5th, on which we commemorate,
the Holy Martyr Caritina of Amisus, on the 5th of the month we celebrate the memory
of the Holy Martyr Caritina.
Saint Caritina lived at Amisus in Pontus at the time of the Emperor Diocletian in the years 284 through 305.
She was bought as a slave, but her master Claudius brought her up as his own daughter.
She lived for Christ, spreading the good news of salvation to those around her,
and so came to the notice of a governor, Count Dmitius.
He sent a letter to her master ordering him to send Caritina to him,
so as to establish whether she was, in fact, a Christian.
Claudius could have no doubt of the result of this examination,
and was so grieved at the prospect of losing her that he put on saccloth and wept bitterly.
But Caritina was full of the joyful confidence of the Lord's disciples.
Master, she consoled him, do not grieve, but be glad,
because I am going to be offered as an acceptable sacrifice to God for my sins and for yours.
Handmade of God, he answered,
remember me in the kingdom of heaven.
Then he sent her to the Count.
The young girl was undaunted as she stood before the consular tribunal and boldly confessed Christ.
They shaved her head in order to shame her,
but her hair grew immediately again by the power of God,
so they scalped her and set burning coals on her head.
They drove flaming spits into her bosom, burnt her sides with torches,
and threw her into the sea with a heavy stone around her neck.
But the divine power once more came to her aid,
and she appeared again before the Count to show that the faith of Christians is stronger than all the tortures he could devise.
After putting her to more torments, they decided to place her in a brothel.
The saint prayed to be spared this and gave up her soul to the Lord.
Her holy relics were thrown into the sea,
but they were found miraculously cast upon the shore by her master Claudius,
who gave them honorable burial.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.